you
you
what's going on guys i see some of you
in the chat already saying that you got
you got this armor
i i see some of you already saying that
you got this armor i don't know how i
feel about that
i do not feel
good about that
bear with me guys bear with me
dad play the campaign
i cannot confirm or deny that i cannot
confirm or deny that
right now
if you see
it says
the multiplayer event
that's what we're talking about right
now
we're talking about the multiplayer
event
guys out here trying to get me in
trouble
why should i feel proud of you
uh dawn of taco what'd you do man what'd
you do
what'd you do
proud of all the chat man the chats the
chats the chat
i got to put that in better
visit the free pass
the event there it is
yeah you can get like 10 minutes i'll
play a game uh while i wait for you
[Music]
hey let's play a game real quick let's
play a game real quick while we wait for
uh
while we wait for hustle
we gonna play a game
win or lose
[Music]
we still winning
oh yeah man cool i ain't got the armor
yet
um
hold up
oh so it's level five it doesn't take
much at all does it
or is this the the the big one
21.
so it doesn't take much to get it level
five
at least they give you the option but i
think
that one's the
the overall one i don't think that's the
waiting for hustle anyone else want to
join in man
we got room
i'm not using oh both these weapons are
hot garbage i don't like this
wow
i don't know how to use the needle
i don't like the randomness of this
where it just changes over and over
again
but i can get down on using this man
i got the riposte or two
i'm not in a voice chat yet
what's up
happy birthday
you chase it
are you chasing
where you go
what's up
got the hammer
gotta drop the hammer
we gotta drop that hammer
i like having a good melee weapon who
you going for
oh
he had that spike one man
one clip is auto kill
all right man let's try let's try it
let's try it let's go
let's get like mid-range though i feel
like we need mid-range
oh
you got a sword
let's use the sword
i don't trust this dude
oh gosh i really like the gravity wow he
took my gran i don't think i dropped the
gravity hammer
i might have i don't know i might i
might have dropped it
br
in this
got that kill assist because i took his
shields
kill assist because i took the shields
don't want to get hit by whatever that
thing is back there
wow
it's a really horrible shot
the mangler
what's up
peekaboo
we like to know where we're going
why how did he kill me i didn't even
take damage
what's up splendid
lost the lead
all right this is the hydra
refill this
wow
i don't like just random weapon swaps i
feel like i need something a little bit
more realistic and why did i get the
hydra again
at least i got the shotgun i guess
and i got a grappling hook so i guess
it's not
like the
whole wow i need my assault rifle gun
my salt rife or my br
that's cool black roan it just hit me up
with uh
with that gamertag
yeah i need that shot
oh he needed to reload it
got like i guess it could be
what's up
why
i don't know why i didn't hit
dying like three times over and over
again
that swords on the other side of the map
and i got this stupid hydra again
my heart is pounding and i don't even
have one
[Music]
gotcha
[Music]
where's the next prey
oh
that was terrifying to watch
yeah i do need to learn how to use every
weapon
yeah get out of here with that nonstop
repulsor required
oh there's some over there
damn
why do they keep giving me this plasma
rifle
five minutes remaining
man i can't use this thing to save my
life
oh that's annoying me what's going on
chat man what's going on
pistol and whatever this is called
no one died
victory oh we won
level four thirty four got one overkill
one one triple kill one double kill all
these probably happened in the same time
all right so i am leveling up
what's up
jabber man what's up jabber i appreciate
everyone for coming through man i know
this is i know that show we ain't really
doing it today like to me
if they ain't nothing to talk about
there ain't no reason for us to waste
our time you know waste obviously you
guys are for the smoke regardless and i
appreciate that the iop community is
always here regardless what we talking
about because you guys enjoy our
personalities our inputs on stuff but to
me if we're going
to not have a whole lot to talk about we
might as well play games
so you know we're going to get some
people up in here man we're gonna make
it a community thing you guys want in
just tell me i'll send the invites you
know if we get enough people that want
to join in and have some fun you know
hit me up hit me up
because then we'll we'll start some
custom games man we'll start some custom
games
let's see who's all on here
let's see here
this is my brother he's playing
oh that's cool
[Music]
can you look at the store
oh that look i don't know guys
[Music]
this this stance might be it
this sense i need this stance in my life
i need this stance in my life
all right we'll probably be streaming
for a little bit i need this stance in
my life is it in
the
is it in the the season pass i doubt it
but we gonna look
all right drunken then just stop me
do it
do it
i'm pending pending
i don't know if you savage enough to
stomp me pindi
20 dollars i know man i know
i'm sitting here looking at it like real
suspect like do i really want to spend
20 dollars man do i really want to do
that
do i really want to spend
20 dollars what the hell is this thing
even called
you know what i know this is suicide for
me
hold this
are you coming down here
you coming down here
oh i knew i was done man the moment i
saw that sword i knew the fate was
already decided
i want to kill someone with this
i want to hit someone with this
someone's got to get this work
i'm still undetermined who's getting
this work
don't run from me
oh he had a sword he's just chilling
there that was a that was kind of a
little [ __ ] move man
i need a better weapon something that i
can use
that really ain't it okay i can get down
with this
wow
i don't like the random switching
weapons thing man i really don't
and i definitely don't like what i look
at these weapons they give me
i'm just not that good with these
weapons
[Music]
yeah man i'm just not good with these
random weapons
it's fiesta like
i don't like look at this they gave me
other weapons i don't know i don't even
know how to use these weapons
like is this like a shotgun
it looks like it rotates off walls
all right so this isn't too bad
i might need to go to the range and
actually learn how to use these weapons
so i got my grappling hook
yeah get out of here
what's going on
get out of here
oh i think i ran out of weapon i like
that weapon
wow
yeah i heard that commando was good in
the beta but i didn't really play the
bait a whole lot
there we go i got something i can use
don't die fab i'm coming
wow
isn't that in the sentinel
maybe it was just too broken that's why
they got rid of it
well they didn't get rid of it but they
they nerfed it's
damn man i can't use these
these guns
i like that other gun
i got used to that other gun
[Music]
jesus man
i missed like five shots
i'm a
i'm a close range character and they
keep giving me these weird-ass guns
is that the dude that was shooting me
have weight of victory
is that the dude that was shooting
me lost the lead
i wish i had like
something else
enemies hurt
wow he killed that dude turned around
and killed me long before we could do
anything about that
oh there we go we got
i'm streaming
just put it down
who's gonna get it
give me that sword
where is everybody
wow
oh my god
the hell was he shooting me there's a
banshee on the map
we lost the lead
how is there a banshee on the map
oh gravity hammer against gravity hammer
who wins
nope
i just don't like
i i feel uncomfortable with certain
weapons because i don't use them very
often
victory
whiplash
grand slam
double kill
you did it
i saw the whole thing
yeah i hate this map too this map's not
that good
yeah but they gave me the commando i
mean everyone knows this game's not that
great
i'mma hide behind this one
targets
get close
where'd they go
grand slam
killing spree
get off my mans i've never seen so many
phones break at once
i just i think it's too open
i think it's too open man i'll be right
with you i think it's too open
oh it's actually called the get good map
all right next i gotta get good my hands
up
hands up gotta get good
i never said it should be in a removed
i never said that you guys said it
should be moved i never said it should
be moved all right who wants to jump in
here
who wants to jump in here
i will play one game
huh
so i'm in the tv
i need some kind of linker does anyone
know
an object a tool
so say
yeah yeah i'm open to it man uh
just join in on lord addicts
four two seven eight
always down to play with the round man
always down to play with the round
hold up guys
i gotta switch stuff around
[Music]
yeah i i see you uh hustle that's why
i'm switching mics
[Music]
xbox wireless headset all right so let
me go in here
all right hold up let
i'm going to join the discord right now
hustle but we might have to join an xbox
live party if we get people joining
join addicts for a hustle
all right all right
you both should be able to hear me
good
there we go
there we go
everything sounds awesome
yeah i haven't i haven't myself came
across the hackers yet
but i'm assuming they up in there
[Music]
how about trey
yeah i can hear you hustle let me turn
you up
no we can it's cross play we just have
to do xbox live for the communication
part
but we we don't have to do it right now
i'm talking about if other people want
to join and they don't have discord
let me make sure you guys can hear
hustle go ahead and talk also
all right hold up
all right so if it doesn't let me
choose all right guard talk
cancel
all right so it's not good they're not
gonna hear you
let me see if i can do something about
that
i need to find a better way of
channeling all this stuff
yeah
i was wondering because the way i could
the wacom have you come through my audio
is uh you're on the desktop
yeah
that's how it's going to hold up
all right try to talk now
all right let me switch let me switch
this
all right now try to talk
try to talk
all right so clearly i don't i don't
even hear you now so
all right now try to talk
hello
hello
hello
oh my gosh man this pc stuff
testing
testing
see now
this this won't be talking about pc
stuff now i can't even hear him and
hello
oh discord's messing up it's connecting
hold up
this is just ridiculous
it's always discord man it's always
discord
call
my microphone
hello
hello
oh my god it's it's
it is it's way easier with console uh
with console like the amount of bulls
stuff that goes on
is insane
[Music]
let me shut down discord and reopen it
because that's
that's just discord for me
everything working just fine
yeah yeah yeah i don't need to hear you
[Music]
hello
still connecting
hello hello
see now i have no connection whatsoever
it won't let me go into any of my voice
apps
hello
[Music]
i guess we'll just have to play a game
until discord
and
after this game
[Music]
fiesta
and we
win i sent him the message
this gives us an edge
all right did you join hustle
i sent you the invite
uh
oh afk dude
we're gonna have to deal with the audio
thing here in a second guys after this
match
i don't i don't know why
pc got to be so damn complicated
ninja
it's always gotta be so complicated for
no reason
i don't know where he thought he was
going with that
another one down
drop wall
so i'm not going up there
oh my god i was switching
we should compromise just be making it
it's just pc dude it's just so
ridiculous
where's another one
yep it is
it's that shotgun thing yeah we'll have
to do the xbox live party we'll do it
after this game
figure out what's going on
because discord decided that working
isn't a uh
a plausible option
oh rockets
no i'm hating on discord
next discord is
is so unreliable
they wonder why nobody want to use their
service
he killed me with that gun i was killing
him with so i guess it's kind of even
a little bit
can i have some help here
oh my god you know what's special i had
hey god i was like you need
hosting in your channel what do you
think host crap gamer
why'd he come up in this conversation
ain't nobody was talking about that man
what's up what's up
deep
i feel like he deflected me
he's got that spike gun
too bad it don't work
oh
what it wow
avoid getting skewered oh look got
nothing against anyone man
you know
it's just
our brands and his brands don't
uh make sense for them to collide with
each other but i got nothing against
crap gamer
you know i don't i don't hate his his
hustle you know he wants to get that
money to get the money
i'm not gonna hate on it
it's just not how i would do things if
my channel
but you know then again my channel
as much as i do need to be more
consistent with it so the only person i
can blame
for my lackluster
viewership is myself because i should be
a lot more
open to making content
and i'm gonna work on that
[Music]
i only got two shots left
oh he's grappling hooked up
oh
i did as much as i could man
pvp not paper
look i'm doing okay
19-7 put some respect on my name a
little bit
just a little bit i don't you don't even
respect me a lot just a little bit
not a lot just a little bit
okay
okay
[Music]
five minutes remaining
seems like they inside boys
seems like they inside
they inside boys
that's all i'm saying man just a little
respect
not even a lot just a little bit
help you boy out man help your boy now
let's see if this
this discord stuff working here
all right it is hustle come back to the
[ __ ] discord is active we up in here
we working
but we still probably should go to a
windows thing i'm gonna
if they show um
[Music]
i don't know if they're going to show
help late at the game awards
i hope so
i think the hellblade is a definitely
something
good to show
are you back yet hustle
hold up
all right yeah can you hear me
yeah hey
all right so um let's get you in this in
this windows uh thing so this is the one
you sent me i'm gonna send you a party
invite did you get it
uh i gotta figure out where it's gonna
go because i got windows windows
hold on just control
hold on how you pull up uh
do i gotta log into xbox
game nice yeah you have to log into xbox
windows g's how you bringing up the the
game ball
okay well let me do this then hold on
hold on let me jump all the way up cuz i
got this on full screen on my one
thing
so how do you get out of this
okay hold on
exit the desktop
but sting
i'll minimize thing for a second
okay hold up
xbox
open this because
anyone that wants to join and play some
send me a message
oh yeah
send that join again
all right
because some of you uh sent me a
friend's request but i i just accepted
like three of them so i don't know who's
who
did you get that
i got the game pass one up is that the
one should i have cause i don't use it
so i wouldn't know just push control g
do you see it
no
oh
[Music]
control g will get you access to the
windows
it's not working oh let me see something
all right then just go into your search
bar and type in gamepad uh game bar
i'm trying to figure out what okay xbox
game bro
oh
[Music]
yes you got we we need two more we can
have two more
but um you guys got to send me messages
so i can
know who to invite so it's just the next
two people will get it
you know what i think i gotta sign in
from here from my streaming pc to do
this
uh let me make sure i got the right
login give me one second
we might have one
it looks like we're gonna have too many
people we might have to do uh
some kind of custom games
that's fine fine where's my
notes
okay
yeah my my setup a little different
because we don't typically because i
don't typically use the
the xbox joint what was uh going on with
this school do you know
i don't know it was it wasn't working
for me very well
[Music]
are you in the xbox live really
try to leave them
papa big papa you have
you
can get invited to the party keep in
mind uh i'm in both
so i'll be able to hear you guys but i'm
still
instructing um
hustle how to get in here
backbreaker send invites like if you
guys want just send me a message there
you go
uh yo
i don't know that that law again
let's see let's see
try again
[Music]
what the
yo
this joint crazy boy
don't accept that back breaker
i ain't been on hannah good lord a lot
of these okay
all right big [ __ ] just give me one
second i got to
open up this profile
oh yeah i'm lost
all right so now
add a thing i'm in here too
more options
i think if i click on your name
does that help me at all
all right so
wait a minute do i have to install this
no sign now
let me change
give me one second i'm trying to
[Music]
microsoft needs to be a little bit
better
all right there's him
there's your your back breaker
all right so it looks like we got two
[Music]
yeah let's see what happened
because it says you're logged on
invite
i am
but the okay the last thing i see is
something that happened 21 21 hours ago
it's the hustle motive at eight right
yeah
yeah just
i just sent it again
i hear it
oh it's over here
all right okay all right let's leave
discord so i can get in there
hello
yeah i can hear you guys
um
i don't know yet that's probably
something on here
so
foreign
all right sounds good all right all
right you guys should be able to hear
them fine now i apologize for that we
had some technical difficulties man we
had my video difficulties
hey you definitely apologize because
that's definitely your bet
this is this is what happens when you
use this code all the time i don't use
xbox one online oh you know that man
all right so let me get these
individuals in here
we got
back breaker here's your invite
and papa
there's your invite
oh man
[Music]
what
oh
well i'm here
yeah you're here i'm not a party
okay all right
[Music]
for most of it
i accidentally
sent another invite tonight
okay
yeah back breaker if you're there man uh
all right there we go
all right now i can send you guys the
invite
is my idiotic self
all right okay now i see y'all too i i
wa i instead of sending an invite to the
game i sent an invite to the party since
i want to since i'm on pc what ended up
happening
is it just started a new party so
oh okay
if i ctrl g
uh right know
i'm ready in your game
oh okay
i think hustle is the only one not in
the game
there hustle
okay
wait how do you accept that why'd you
i don't know um
it's the pc thing man it's the pc
i don't know man
don't worry about it like there's only
so much i can help with man
all right so let's do fiesta this is why
i like steam so much because you know on
steam all you gotta do is play are we
friends
can you invite me to a thing we got a
five dollar super chat from
mandiago mick thickness i i don't know
man
i i don't know i don't know
don't look at me like that i attempted
it all right i attempted it this is a
fantastic game we'll be playing in a
couple hours don't look at me like that
hustle don't look at me like that
man then go make thickness i'm gonna
need you to change your name
if he's confident in his thickness then
who are we to tell he can't be
i'm about to give him a nickname or
something
you gonna call that man's thickness
that's what you gonna call it i had a
guy i don't know if they ever did this
in halo before but like but the mode
that we're playing is kind of like
dodgeball like and um and gears they
they do this the word like you'll get a
kill and with every kill that you get
they switch weapons it wouldn't halo
they don't do that that's when you die
but
it's called fiesta i i i fiesta i don't
like it
it's fire five it's better than halo 5
oh okay i never played this in halo 5. i
just played like it is amazing
okay i mean what the destroyer was cool
to me i got i got a kill i got a couple
of uh i got a noscope with the uh
they called that thing the obscure or
whatever that was
that was that's my first time using that
weapon i like that
if
you and help you out to get better with
all the weapons
you get you get used to them
[Music]
he got the skin on one the red and black
um yeah
it cost me one does look good
it costs you a dollar yeah
i got a sniper
look at that cost me 10. what the heck
hey it means
let's see if i can get at least one hero
all right let's
give me the story
oh come on y'all oh
what about the body who all over here i
got him though i got him he got me by
he's not dead
well i don't know what gun that was i
don't like that
don't get that
i got
all right here we go here we go
man
people always got better guns than me
like they got like
better
one-shot hit guns than me
they keep giving me stuff i don't use
and i don't even like this shield
yeah i kind of thought of them
i picked up the sword
oh i hit somebody
wow my bad
i ain't
this is a little different to get used
to
my favorite abilities definitely
what's up
i didn't see that rocket coming oh
hold me down hold me down hold me down
i drop skill
hustle thickness thinks it's funny
what the where died
yeah thickness thinks it's funny oh [ __ ]
this whole time also
i mean we gotta we gotta like double up
stick together yeah a little bit just a
little bit not a lot just a little bit
grab the equipment oh yeah
damn baby
well give me that again [ __ ]
oh i didn't expect that shield
okay
[ __ ]
i think he picked me a soul but ain't
nothing
it might be like one shot left in that
school
there's 40 left in this sword
the four swings
[Music]
uh i think house was on pc and the rest
of us are on xbox
yeah okay
[Music]
see because of hustle we're having to
play with the pc terrorists that's why
we're
[Music]
i was wondering how you got it
challenge complete so wait
okay epic bad drop okay got that
oh my god look at them stats
that was a rough game
[Music]
you got to buy one of those kids at it
you got to buy one of them
one of those skins
i i know the exact skin i'm guessing
use the microphone point they gave you
on the game pass
oh they gave us they gave us
points for being on gamepads
yeah microphone war points yeah
you go turn into gift cards you got to
redeem them first you gotta go bang and
redeem them right yeah or no not being
like you know there's a little app on
the xbox i don't know about the pc
section but the xbox you got a reward
then you go redeem that's him and you
what you want to redeem
maybe i like looking like walmart
look my [ __ ] looks all worn and
everything looks like the paint's coming
off maybe that's just my flavor like
that ain't my flavor no i'm getting all
that i'm getting the space astronaut i
forget what they call it put up i saw
merc with it earlier they kind of match
our colors
oh i hate that sentinel [ __ ]
he's got the skill
yeah
[Music]
that gun was opening halo 5
no later
yeah it's back too bad right now
oh oh okay there oh a sword
yep
are you gone
the lead
nobody down here no more someone's down
here
don't try like you're not here
i'm not stupid
[Music]
oh you had a thrusters we'll take the
thrusters let's go
oh i thought i had him i thought that
was a great shot
oh my god
i don't like the covenant weapons man
get rid of this nonsense like
they take so long to reload
it's like that's all they give me man
i'm human let me play with human weapons
earlier so what's the point but don't
tell nobody don't don't tell them
we'll keep it to ourselves
wow that dude with the sword no no no
back up he's got a sword back up yeah
you got the one that i dropped
oh no wow
i got
oh wait somebody's out here help me help
me
sneak them up oh no okay that's my job
well i guess i got a rocket launcher
we got one
the horror
oh
[Music]
did my game crash yes it did
damn it crash
[ __ ]
damn that thought it was on that xbox
series x you you wouldn't have that
issue wasn't it yeah
but i just wanna
you would you would be in here right now
with this play in this game
i better say how am i talking to y'all
if i don't get no end of that no
[Music]
it should be fine
[Music]
yeah we're we're done
wait yeah that that's that's right man
no crash is on the xbox
you know because he was on that pc stuff
you know they they got his gun they
gotta they gotta equal the balance
somehow they gotta do it somehow
you gotta go talking that [ __ ]
you know my internet was off or
something
i wouldn't be in here right now so
and i get the little red thing around my
my routers my router's fine so
oh man
i guess me getting booted or whatever
i guess it doesn't um
i guess it doesn't save any of those
stats does it
no i don't think so
we'll call that the pc tax
oh man
[Music]
[Music]
all right what was i wanting to do
oh yeah i wanted to check
okay
updated
as well i didn't get a steam update
either
you need another
invite uh come on hold on i'm gonna
close up some stuff
ea
there's another one that always opens up
close that one
oh yeah all right go ahead and send me
that
while the wrestling show got that
became average so
oh
i like how you level up both like you
level up the
your regular battle pass and the event
pass at the same time
that would be the pain if it was
separate and you had to choose for the
week
yeah danny what we'll do is if we get a
couple people
then we'll just start some customs up
yeah i might actually get like king in
them in here and we can do customs
xbox
you better get king of here
if we get if we get people with customs
and stuff
xbox game balls playing with some other
people right now i'm in here right
yeah
yeah yeah okay all right
oh i don't know you're not in the game
no no no no no not in the game in the um
anything the way y'all can hear me well
y'all don't always hurt me though yeah
we're talking to you yeah we're just
talking [ __ ] the whole time
yeah i know i know
look y'all know
i know i got your brain on work right
sometime
i feel that
i've been up to three this morning man i
i get a passport
hey i'm with you there i've been up
since two
oh jeez
well i'm passed out at six last night so
then i woke up the team was like i guess
i'm up
i'm gonna need you and you and me to get
some damn sleep what's going on sir like
now uh i work for the post office and
it's holiday season so
you got some little gift
sleep schedule is not a thing this month
or next month
all right do you want me to send you
another invite
hustle huh hold on hold on i think it's
because they said this game had trouble
booting up because i was in two to two
different places at once
[Music]
oh that's why
huh
so i think in order for me to talk to
y'all i need to have you on the stream
at pc but not the gaming pc
that would make sense
you said it doesn't make sense i said
that would make sense
yeah so hold on i think that's the
reason why
that might that may have been part of
the confusion
let me see something see additive y'all
was on steam
like god intended
hold on
if we was on steam i'd have a heart
attack
i'm gonna say it phil gave us the series
x though so
but did he
did he really hold on hold on
wait a minute i mean he did
i can do so i can join your game this
way
that's it it's already since you're
already in there
let's see i'm in y'all five team i see
uh
yo you gotta change your name too back
breaker
yeah
hey
then i see a big poppy you gotta change
your name
what's going on
my name is big poppy and i
really particularly i just want you to
call me big poppy like
man i said my name is my name i got to
figure out how to add y'all but i think
i've got to add y'all to the xbox
thing as opposed to sting i think it's
too expensive so okay i'll figure that
out
i figured out but i'm here
i'm here
i mean we can talk to you so it's good
some some way you know i mean i'm in the
game now i mean i'm in y'all fire team
man
this
all right it says he's here
oh boy this is
this is something uh man my points are
going away you know oh man i'm well no i
like that little samurai though i
definitely do but i'm buying the um
the space station i think that's the
esports team name like i said i saw merc
with that earlier that's the album
that's the
the black and gold one mm-hmm that's
that
that's a good
troubleshooter's joint too so it that
kind of works itself out works itself
out
oh
okay he's loading up i about to say i
still in the game on
uh you're still there right
okay okay
[Music]
oh hold the bring fire fight
[Music]
let's fire fight
[Music]
okay all
right all right so if i do decide to
upload this pc problems y'all like what
you want me to do
i don't even know obviously there is
there is a solution
you might not like it but there's a
solution
look you get that little man man we got
a console for you hey look at that
little thing
i spent i spent like two grand on that
game with pc about to do man two grand
on a gaming pc can't play halo very well
i got
it's only it y'all
some people
some people bought 300 little man and
they having less problems than you
they probably ain't having no problems
that's why i do enjoy that
games they crash but it's red
yo this one's in my intervention i said
wait a minute
i'm trying to flank them poppy there's
somebody in there
yeah
oh my god yo kill him y'all
what's up there you go adam i wish you
would have killed me
[ __ ]
there you go
yeah guys i i don't particularly like
the first event the it being this like i
don't nothing against this one but i
don't like playing with random stuff
but i'll take that hammer
oh wait i didn't that means that him the
first time which is
i don't know how to feel about that
oh man
oh there's no luck to that he won't get
me with that sword
he just even miscalculated the wrong
time
nah he he just he saw it was lord addict
coming up on him and he said you know
what i'm gonna take that out uh they got
power soldering gravity how many i'll be
careful
oh
what's up
oh
i got hit a little bit just a little bit
i got hit
i still have faith in the process though
all right do somebody got close
skewer
oh my god
slipping up my fingers right there man
oh i don't like that whatever the gun
that
i'm gonna be sick
oh wow wow there's two people with
swords
imma try to snipe it
wherever they're at
oh my god
he's got a sword too
mm-hmm
wow ooh
nope
going this way
oh my god
it's like half the team's got a sword
or a gravity hammer
that other gun that little laser gun
actually dropped to that i didn't know
that i never realized
got me reloading
oh my god
oh oh wow okay so that
okay
i got it
the shock ones
i think that's what i heard yeah
i was gonna say i may have to camp
no
another one down i killed whoever only
busted his shield with my rocket
launcher apparently
wow
it's it's okay but i i would prefer
something different like i'm not gonna
lie like i really don't like the random
stuff
i'm i would
like i would prefer something like grif
ball over
this your fall would be fun
to play halo
5.
thank you hustle
grand slam whatever that means
can we come back let's see if we can
come back let's see
goddammit
[Music]
what's going on in the mountains i'll
tell you that
[Music]
oh we gotta do this 10 times right
is that how you is how it works
i think so yes i just saw something that
says um
well enough now fiesta fiesta that's um
something else um
i told jay-z's on what i forget what it
said
they showed me how many matches we did
because apparently we did five dollars
official you have a spot
uh for one more player we don't but
there's a couple people that want to
play so we'll probably do some costumes
here uh in a little bit so stay stick
around
and then we'll we'll we'll hit it off
with some customs man
oh so 50 years
this
well looks like i'm starting off with
the with the needle
it just had it on my head for one night
i didn't equip that
all right
oh this was the map that y'all was on
before the shot in light
yeah i'm not the biggest fan whoops
i guess i couldn't grapple hook across
the map on this
oh they got the beat going holy oh hello
oh oh oh
man why did they show up with two
vehicles i feel like that's a little
unfair just a little bit
we didn't we didn't
um they did this when i was playing
capture the flag popping them down
get out
oh
okay
we couldn't go for them they spawned
with them basically
oh dear
oh they ain't got a ghost
and the sad thing is we get random
weapons so i there's not a lot we can do
unless we get like a rocket launcher
i got something for the i got something
for them i ran one of them over though
i wanna spawn no they're not even using
the weapons
wow
wow
i shot that thing three times with the
rocket
police there running
keep your head down
it seems like they're out of uh vehicles
i think we blew them all up
but now i got the the damn commando
switch that out immediately
i wasn't feeling that
big papa come on get off let's go
let's go
let's go big five
come on big papa
oh my gosh
y'all hold it down
ah
got you
no they they flipped spawn
oh
picked it up
where is he
okay
[Music]
let me get that banshee let me get that
banshee
whoa
i didn't even see him
he must have grappled
that's a really horrible place to have a
band she's not a lot of room to move i
should've i should have used the gravity
camera to try to destroy that thing
i'm not sure if it would have worked
though
get on that bad
oh
i just want this game to be over with
i'm gonna be real with you i i'm not
having no fun playing this event like at
all
that's better side man
it's power weapons the game huh
get out
i gotta fight
hang on
all right there's a waffle
oh wow
they got the walk
[Music]
wow
all right i just appreciate when i have
choice in what's going on
another one down
minutes remaining
well
i just want this game to end
yeah one more to be over
there you go oh don't worry so
thankfully it's over
[Music]
yeah
definitely getting our stuff rocked man
definitely getting our stuff wrong
i i felt like that was unfair from the
start we started that game
tell me how we was supposed to act
and keep in mind
we were getting random drops it's not
like i couldn't just go get the
grappling hook
like
that wasn't an option chat
i want you to tell me how i can help me
all i hear is complaining that's all i
do i complain that's all i do
all right so so we can stop this add a
complaint like you guys be acting like
it's some new stuff it's not
all right
well the next match would be better i'm
sure
as long as there's no vehicles
facts
i don't even be thinking jump in them
joints man
well see you died too much let's start
there that is some very great criticism
from you nate that's awesome criticism
from you
because uh
me dying is definitely feels like a
criticism that well i personally feel
like i could work on
dying is a solid foundation to start on
i don't know how i feel about see the
thing is about this mode is everyone
could spawn with rocket launchers and
there's nothing you can do
more vehicles
[Music]
why is there so much complaining going
on in this room
what's up full-time
what up though
i come to see what the lord is talking
about and all i see is a a person
complaining
why you guys be acting surprised
oh okay
but we wasn't winning
this is not the last one that last one
we should probably stick together too to
a point
that's a good idea
i'm getting double-teamed and then
someone's got a banshee who gave this
man a banshee
i got to do better i ain't got to be
better than that
all right this is the plan all right
this is the plan all right we're going
to find that banshee
and i'll take it oh i got a scooter
yeah that's the plan that's the plan
yes the pleasure all right
said
i don't care about your plan
i said don't worry i got it i feel like
we got to blame hustle
and someone just sniped him back record
just broke his back it looked like it
was more of his neck
uh man i feel like some of these people
got crazy aim with these precision
weapons i feel like these are some pcp
when you say he's coming near me you
gotta let me know inside cause i could i
could prepare better for that
[Music]
oh my god
all right let's go let's go let's go
everyone on me
no watch out for the chocolate
what is he shooting us with
[Music]
see it's because everyone's got rockets
everyone's got everything
it's fiesta
i don't like fiesta
and yes
is
it's like the worst thing we could have
ever played
do we have to play fiesta
what are you the event
all right let's get him about papa let's
get him pop
[Music]
everyone's got rocket launchers like
i like play i don't like playing halo
when like literally everyone's got a
power armor a power weapon like it's so
crazy
y'all be careful because they're also
looking at the spawn too because i just
came to life and then i do that
oh oh no they're just sitting back there
here goes nothing
[Music]
oh that's what that is
i tried i tried but i couldn't grab the
i couldn't do the grappling hook quick
enough but i killed them both though
yeah oh
all right
wow two shotgun shots
close quarters
and he just he just he just laughed did
you see that forte
drove him off the mat bro
oh yeah that's going that's going on
tick tock
it would have been way better if uh
oh i'm not going up there that that
that's not happening
there's like 30 people up there they all
was up there
they really fight each other like
they're really they're really
lost by like they're really surrounding
each other like that
my heart is pounding
they're huddling up mm-hmm
where'd they all go
there's one here
no don't get in there get out get out of
it get out of it
no
vehicle stop jumping over here
[Music]
i'm hopping up in this vehicle
they hate me right now
um
i love him when i'm getting killed
well
[Music]
wow
i don't like these new weapons dude like
it's i feel like they don't work like i
did the lightning thing and i just
and they gave it to me again
yeah i got the same thing like three
times in a row too
oh there's 30 reward
tears and i've hated
every bit of this [ __ ]
all right
i wish i got about to go over there
[Music]
all right fourteen you're about to get
on
uh i'm already going when i'm doing um
trying to get stuff ready for dps
tonight oh yeah yeah yeah yeah this goes
thanksgivings on thursday so we're doing
it tonight
i'm almost almost completely one of
these towns can i see what i almost
completed no pretty cool
hmm
not gaming addy complaining about halo
how dare you sir
i don't like that i don't like the
the energy you're throwing out the world
right now
my energy is my energy is just sir what
about yours
all right so apparently
it glitched out let me resend the
invites
everyone just join on me
okay i think i'm in a game already
i don't know
can i jump out would i be penalized for
it i guess that's the other question but
this is like social right
yes social oh yeah we should be fine
[Music]
okay
what's up
where have you been
working i stopped sending you invites
because you were never true
well it's because i've been when you
send them itself i'm like
everyone's here
okay yeah
all right then i'll join you guys it's
fine now we'll hop out we gotta jump
um
we still need two more people
i just joined off of just one dog
all right so everyone in the chat
put a one if you would do a custom games
sorry
how many people
is here that
would be interested in doing a custom
game you want to do a custom games forte
i can't do them right now i'll be
done doing this i will be able to
when i'm done with this
all right i can't join you guys
which one is it
wait wait wait custom games how many
people y'all got
there's a few in the chat that want to
play
oh
you better smoke them
oh
can't be can't be
the youtuber can't lose to the students
i gotta find out how many people want to
do
i'm just talking
where were you at hustles the other day
we were playing um we played against um
no i reckon
no that was saturday no no i know i know
i ended up yeah where were you high i
wasn't hot and i fell asleep when
backlog was the one
two in the morning that's all yeah
i was like where hustles at no no no
they ran already
do you have one like games in a row to
get these
i hope not
boy
oh boy
oh boy
so we got one
or do you have to complete challenges
you have to complete challenges
no i don't know i'm only ranked two
so i don't know
we've played three games
something we can do
five on
no we need one more person to make it
even
no those are event challenges
okay
earn assistance
[Music]
you know is but that
this like
daily thing is pretty bad but after
doing the the weekly events and stuff
like i could see how
like what they originally thought was
going to be able to be played you know
what i'm saying
because i've leveled up pretty fast
after doing the um just the weekly
events
killer enemy with the sidekick pistol
all right let me try to work on that
there
shouldn't that shouldn't be too
difficult either
okay
and it's on my head around 7 30. i get
my dog
got to get my doggy
i know she outside
so adam when you about to play that
library of runa
the what
it's on game pass
it's a korean rpg
what a good time
you
it just think
it's just like yu-gi-oh
but like 10 times harder than what it is
you killed it 10 times harder yes
fiesta
i'm just waiting for elden ring
personally
oh you got it
uh-huh i'm going to pass by that one oh
god what is on his arm
i love the souls games um i'm excited
for for that look like a yu-gi-oh disc
oh
that's on my arm oh i don't want it
the repulsor
oh
i keep getting these shotguns
all right let's see here
well buddy
where is everybody
off there over here
i feel like the internet
of course he has a sword
oh they're left
i was saying they were over here but i
think they went over to add it
of course he's got a sword
oh
oh okay you can oh you get points for
that another
[Music]
oh
i think the battle pass is worth the ten
dollars
because i mean you're gonna play the
game anyway uh and get some stuff from
it i do think they need to change some
themes and stuff
all right
let me hop on the damn board
[Music]
what's going on
also behind us
they were over here
everyone's got rocket launchers man
or power source don't forget that
there's a rocket launcher in the back of
it
at least this is an okay
enemy field's down
wow
wow
[Music]
give me that
wow did he just no scope me are that
close in the air
damn you better put you in the highlight
bet you bet you bet you if i look he
plays on pc oh
i got two melee weapons i'm not sure how
how smooth it's gonna go
papa needs help
hope this gives us an edge
oh no
um
come on
cover me
wow
everything
yeah ryan it's it's a little rough man
it's a little rough man it's a little
rough
can't turn off cross play because
someone here is on pc
[Laughter]
sorry you say my name it's so good
because that's all the that's all
i'm all i'm saying man is this cheating
on console but not quite like that pc
we want one
i don't feel proud of this
there you go there you go
oh get insist
what
huh something's wrong with that scoring
too
i could've swallow i got
okay i got something in the wrist
[Music]
oh i got one assist what yo
all right
i'll do better
all right
so how's everybody going to chat feeling
i hope all is well
i'm down there
and forgot to ask how everybody was
doing oh
now you know in all seriousness i didn't
want to get a series s i just can't seem
to find them though i can't seem to find
them without when i'm ready to go buy
one
you should follow this ball when i'm
looking for it
that never works for me
why did like half the team have rockets
there
yeah
i killed one of those bastards
oh yeah oh my god
i almost got i should have got three of
them though they was all huddled up
together
oh he had he had some
oh
i don't even know what this thing is
that's what i get for being thirsty
and that's no i'm
i need
all right
that
one wow
what's up clay
what's up guys
come on around
come on around here you can't turn off
cross play if you're playing if you're
playing with someone that is on
i feel like the only reason they win is
because they got power weapons man oh
[ __ ]
i mean i can't we can't really complain
we got power weapons too i just feel
like they always got more
they got the better power weapons
shout out to the game do the game you
want i suppose i've been damn boy
i fired a rocket down there
oh they wouldn't let me start it would
let me strike is there a secondary uh
attack with the gravity handle
no nothing weapons
all right
wow i didn't even know he had a gravity
hammer too it's too late
defend defend defend my uh my stuff in
the middle i want that sword
never mind he's they're about to grab it
shoot him once one more
oh i'm not over here
get out of here get outta here get out
of here
oh that's that's bs by the way
i guess i didn't know
oh they won't give me that rocket
launcher back though
double kill i see you
oh there's nothing i think
uh
i don't want to drop the sniper
sword man
you just keep him busy i'm going around
i got one he had a sword
oh okay
oh how did i i wonder how i avoided that
the first time but uh okay
swipe ooh good kill
all right i think that was you added
[Music]
i mean i could have done a lot
oh
i did not see them
since the playing is not looking at the
map y'all been doing that this whole
like town we've been playing
[Music]
oh yeah that's just two more
got some dude in the chat saying this
looks and this looks like uh call of
duty
i won't go that far i'm having fun
i don't know about college dude like if
it felt like hello
we got that definitely feels more halo
yeah i don't know
i'm curious to know when i finished that
though
all right
i finished positive yay yay me i know
what i'm re-uploading to youtube let's
go
just the good games
the facts
everybody know everybody know i'm pretty
bad so that won't really bother me for
[Music]
all right
i want to thank all 71 people in the
chat right now for watching we really
appreciate y'all
um
you know halo is free to play so if
y'all ever want to pull up pull up
let's do that
i hit myself
okay man i'm gonna be real with you uh
uh corey b day on your ass they want to
know what this feels like car gotta be
in that chat defend yourself say what
feels like a car
oh i got in need all right results i
need examples why does it feel like god
it's all jokes though corey but right
really why does it feel like god yeah
because i i'm telling you i'm having a
good time with this i'm two hours kind
of like flew by though
wow you know what he shot me with but it
was it was crazy i think that stories i
don't like it because at any time you
can go against someone for power weapon
and there's a lot of the times where you
can't do nothing about it
[Music]
oh my god i missed him i shouldn't have
missed him though i shouldn't have
missed him
[ __ ] power
[Music]
i was going to joke around and say attic
you might be being stream sniped or
whatever
i mean what am i going to do we'll go
through the the floor and and beat him
come back
he's one shot
not tonight
not tonight
i gotta kill somebody i got it i take it
i got a triple kill oh
that's probably how i got it double kill
required
oh my god
that little room
oh my gosh
he's crouching he's going oh
he got papa get
where are they
by the way
yeah i know
[Music]
hey oh that sucks that gun is garbage
i know i hit him in the head too
my god it's not a bad thing card is cool
back in the just unique and special i
don't think it's back in the day like
the thing is when people say back in the
day
that's what halo was still fresh and
people are getting the fact that
that it's still halo and confusing with
other stuff like it was unique because
it was back in the day no longer back in
the day
hit my
right now what's going on
i think they can happen too i just want
a good weapon just give me a good weapon
please okay rpg is a good weapon
pretty much
he just took my my my rpg guys
can you commit a suicide with it
okay then never mind he's an idiot we're
good
why is that gun do so much more damage
than other people
wow that's why i don't like that weapon
i like the sword
somehow all right everyone group up
group up like we need we we need a
yeah yeah to watch each other's backs
[ __ ]
i'm not jumping out there no more they
got a sniper
let me get
oh my gosh
definitely going back up there
there's one
they need one we need two
ball rockets damn it
the worst way
i'll be right with you i'm gonna be real
tall that's my forward
i
i did nothing
i did absolutely nothing
there's not much you can do when
power weapons fan
now we getting a lot of uh
the the crazy thing is we can do these
these
challenges a lot faster when you have uh
nothing but
uh
nothing but power weapons on the planet
i'm like twenty percent good
i'm about to get that award for assists
i'm surprised i get that a lot soon to
be honest with you
nice
i got to go back and watch backlog i saw
that you were a uh
special guest
that was my my my clone that wasn't me
i
well it was good to see your clone emmy
yeah i told him
i told him they asked for me and and not
him but
i guess he he i think he like knocked me
out i don't know
must have slipped something in my drink
i hit you with the chlorophyll
fiesta
all right
like if you feel like this is like a
little bit like cod i don't agree but
like i'm not gonna tell you that you
have no right to feel that way
i don't i don't agree with it
i do want to say um like this is like a
really good thing to see
everybody yeah i mean
it's like
like even the people who ain't even like
xbox dudes some of the point of this
which is dope
i'm gonna follow you at it
uh
what's the point of me
okay i gotta learn how to use that gun
i'll take that
oh my god
wow
oh i don't know
i don't know what he had
uh cinder shot
maybe
he he got away from me like really easy
rockets
don't take that behind your ass
yo
what gun is that
oh it's a skill okay all right
oh
how are you alive sir
you shouldn't ever run away
wow i don't like these covenant weapons
i don't feel like they do any damage i
feel like they just for shields
kill him
thank god
i got i dropped skill and gravity hammer
wait we got it
the guy with rockets in their attic
man
oh okay that's what i get for standing
on overload
i wish i had oh my god
wow
there's something weird about that he
literally
jumped back
no scoped me and then nah
that's a pc dude there
oh yeah
he's part of the master race
i don't wanna play anymore after that
like no you don't understand how bad
that was
i do want to kind of see
i kind of want to see what happened
and they give me nothing but these
[ __ ] lightning weapons
give me this gravity hammer right
i've never seen so many bones break at
once
wait hit me with that
take your life
no it's okay man let me knock somebody's
shields for hope
hit a muscle
uh i think i got him no i didn't
i got a covenant
ah
left
oh my god
wow
i don't even know what these guns are
shooting me with like i really don't
[Music]
uh
i just want this game to be over with
wow like three people there i couldn't
get enough needles in any of them
because they kept taking turns taking
the needle shot
five minutes remaining
still one of them
well i'm glad it's over
[Music]
yeah that one was a little rough
all right i also don't only probably got
one more game so we're gonna play
something regularly all right we thank
god
power weapon mode boy
start off but
then
um
14 40.
all right
what is the grand finale y'all
at least for me
at least for me
ooh strongholds all right thank you
thank you addict an objective-based
thing though i can
play better
well at least everyone's not gonna be
running around with five
i know
rocket launchers and tell me your papers
and everything
oh wow okay i got an assist thank you
for that
in there too i'm going to be
back up a little bit
stronghold charlie is out
your team
okay he's going for the sword
that's right i forgot that was on this
map
[Music]
okay well i got people
they're going on in whole teams of four
like we're gonna have to
to stay together
all right
targets
wow that stupid sword he's coming free
break no no no no
i got him
okay all right poppy
we're gonna stop
i'm just getting shot from everywhere
yeah
yeah
they just they just stay in the high
ground majority of the time
all right let's just keep a and see
your team score yes i think that's how
we gonna have to go
yeah just keep a and c don't keep trying
to go for all this stuff they're just
a and c don't don't worry about b let
them have b i'm already here
all right a and b a and b
jesus man
your team's story
enemy team
just keep these i need help over here
uh where you at i'm i'm at succeed
they're just always being outnumbered
yeah
on the field
[Music]
all right
i need two of you at sea and two of you
another one
we're we're
letting them just take stuff the moment
we leave it
the enemy is counting so i typically sit
back
all right
i need two of you over here
uh where's here
uh see everyone come on see then we'll
separate from sea
i'm getting jumped
behind
see it's so hard to to get together
oh my god neither one of them
oh [ __ ]
we got hurry up okay
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay we'll take that you guys stay
there stay in the raptors
that guy with a sword
yeah
all right then take c
stronghold
come on
stay all right now stay here come over
here breaker because stay with him stay
with hustle yeah there's two hustle
coming up
active camera inbound oh my god
fighter
don't say it i'll say it okay
all right
guy with the sword
i'm over here b so we should
have at least two of the points
we lost
coming to me
oh oh oh wow
no one's getting close to me
wow
yeah that was about but it's so close to
200.
that would be miraculous there's no way
we can come back from there
we took two we took
we took too long to come together
i'm going here we're back
i think someone's coming i'm chilling
coming from the right too
oh no
he's one guy two guys
oh
the moment they take it's over
we were starting to do better there at
the end but we we needed to come
together like way before then enemy team
scored
[Music]
all right well
that's fine well gentlemen
i make my fair well
it's been a pleasure y'all um hey you're
fine man who wants it's been fun anyone
need to take a hustle spot
how do i
okay there we go
all right
and control g right
yeah
flag
captain slay
[Music]
i'll capture the fire okay
oh my god
items in the stores are overpriced
that's usually what the price is for
this type of model
uh i do think they need to have more
weight like everything in there should
be in the game if you wanted
all right you guys go and i'll try to
keep them off the flag as long as
possible
all right
i'm gonna die
yeah
there's two of them
come up behind you
oh you got me
it's up top popping
yeah i can't get him out of all the way
around
the enemy carrier has revealed
themselves
yeah they got that
enemy flag returned
wow
wow
in two different directions
i'm coming up the side right i'm gonna
need one back at the base with me they
keep coming compared to two
i mean they became packs of threes
oh philly yeah
another one
they're sending it back
yeah i got room for you kids
i'm going around
perfect
hmm
i think that dude saw me
they have our flag not good
i got in the middle
i'm on my way over there right now
they're about to return that
and they got
is going to it we had a box
no but still
smooth you want to play or what
because i don't got much longer left man
[Music]
yeah i definitely got spammed up
you got you got it with the sex box
people unfortunately don't have a life
[Music]
[Music]
seems like this sex box they definitely
trying to
be heading
everyone's stream
see do you be getting them um in your
messages
and your egg box
i haven't really noticed since they did
that filter
beautiful
oh my god dude
i'm getting triple team
up behind you attic
we got the dashes
[Music]
oh my god
struggling
and then
halo man that ring can get lit up at any
time of grenades
pull back a little bit
wow
they had the power
keep getting assist over and over
foreign
did some damage
[Music]
victory
[Music]
uh
wow
i think i closed enough for lunch
[Music]
that's it no man
cinder shot available
they're on that right side
man
two of them over there
where's our team man
guys pull back no
where are you i'm with you
victory
freaking
you may laid him and was on his ass he
still got you with that grenade
i'm gonna grab it for myself this time
[Music]
[Music]
one
i let him kill me i was like that dude
[Music]
[Music]
yeah halo 2 was made a long time ago it
is crazy people are still playing that
game
capture the flag
we got to get we got
payback for that one we lost but
sounds good
oh this is
all right i got a guy on the right going
to skewers
no
[Music]
[Music]
take the flag
right here
they got [ __ ] overshield all that
[ __ ]
return
[Music]
hmm
try to get better
wow
i can't have so much recoil
okay
they know where we are i'll go back to
them when they try to
or die
you're exposed spartan
the enemy carrier
all right
ammo reserves depleting
above us
[Music]
with the flag
reloading
you turn it
oh
the enemy carrier
how do you activate the event is it like
you have to go to the ship playlist
we're not playing the playlist right now
but if you want to we'll play it
the enemy carrier
well he hit me with the flag
yeah he did i did the flight the
graphically hit me with the flag on my
way to
oh my gosh
i don't know what happened there
we might leave uh
we'll probably leave
your flag
defeat
we'll probably leave cross play
all right um let me know hit me up with
you um
oh damn
back out
[Music]
all right let's see here
iron like um i guess people aren't happy
with this uh new um
it's weekly or whatever they call it
this event
hold up how do i leave crossplay
oh not really
huh
i don't know if you turn it off
i think you can only turn it off and
um
and ring
please tell me that you had it oh damn
i'm not i'm in a different match that's
weird
you're in a game
yeah i thought i accepted your game i
thought i was joining him with you well
just quit and join me
is this thing ranked
no that's a
is
oh oh the weapons change up in this
it ever does
oh that's actually kind of tight
it is
oh so oh yeah oh yeah
whoa
are we do you want us to start a game
no no no i might i might quit
i just wanted
we're not
hold on
yeah ice cream
ugh
[Music]
oh
where is it
give me a hole hold the chair so i don't
lean it
alright
grab this so it doesn't fall
all right
did i join
nothing
oh that's a that's a bot
let's just back out
i'm not playing this with a ball i'm
just not doing it oh
left
like the the balls are just horrible
so just leave game
yeah i'm not playing with a ball it's
just not happening
it'd be different if the boss were semi
usable but
they battled
those mother marines
all right let's make sure kids in here
first
all right so it says everyone's here
right
yep i'm here
i only see three
people i don't know they remind us yet
now
so everyone's here
yeah everyone's here
[Music]
i leave my phone out here
my
[Music]
i don't phone
all right let's try this
i don't know why they don't
slow mo
it's crazy to me
damn
but we don't oh this is fearful
yeah
got a double kill
of course people with swords and shields
just dominate in this mode
yep
oh
my god
just dude in that game i was in i was
[ __ ] actually doing something
[Music]
so careful with that thing
he just screamed
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you keep [ __ ] with
me i'm just going to buy everything in
the stupid-ass costumes
i mean they're probably a fiesta right
now they don't have a lot of weapons
from majority time you're going to get a
rocket or
[Music]
are you okay kid are you okay
this [ __ ] is pissing me off
and there's nothing i can do to improve
it
not get killed
one and seven and one assists
i can't even claim anybody's kills
i can't climb anybody's kid
victory
they always give me like this stupid
covenant weapons it's the only ones i
don't want
and of course i i get more assists
gravity hammer is on our side
wow
wow you think it shot me with a crack
weapon
oh a battle rifle nice
oh my gosh man give me a good weapon
wow
two people were scared
my
okay
needs a whole walking four and 12.
grenade out
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wow
what a rocket man
all right
that sucks
oh wow oh i'm curious to be shopping
with a little sniper
wow
oh [ __ ] i ran
up
oh somebody stole my kill thanks to
whoever we should
i could have really used that
to salvage whatever
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] nope nope run just run
wow the game was actually that close
imagine if i actually played decent
i'm trying to imagine it man but you got
to play
damn accuracy was 20 yeah i was all off
14 death that means i got a team high
six
uh yeah let's see what we did you
the whole event like twice during the
case
yeah man i gotta get back onto my halo 5
grain if i could be just as good as i
was in halo 5 in this i'd be comfortable
but is everybody's right are you guys
like what platinum level
oh i haven't started ranked yet i'm
diamond
yeah okay
i'm diamond i think four or five
i'm only diamond one
no
[Laughter]
so much better coming off the tongue
foreign
listen i wasn't ready for when that
wraith came around the corner that one
game
that was
i got it
nice
no it's not nice
yeah but wait on halo infinite
yeah it's not as good as it used to be
but it's like
oh
okay he gets a rocket sure
that that that's the the problem fiesta
man stuff like that going anytime
don't
okay
all right that's the sword i'll take
that and then mine this is one of the
worst maps
wow
didn't have a weapon to shoot in there
ah
wow can you die
[Music]
gave me a pistol and a sniper rifle
got the pickup
now this oh my god i hate using the
sniper rifle
uh yeah i'm on five so yeah this is
probably gonna be like a
16 game okay
wow
this event can kiss my ass
[Music]
great
wow
i just don't enjoy this mode like i
really don't i don't enjoy like because
because there's always the chance that
they have
multiple
rpgs
or skewers
wow i can't get any of that
yeah they just got me this [ __ ]
sketch
wow
okay
thank you it gave me a kill
am i bad
you're fine i wasn't going to kill him
this
gay sniper rifle
so
like poppy's carrying us
dropping seven feet when i just looked
at that scoreboard
snipers and [ __ ]
yeah
it's these pc people man i'm telling you
they're just so accurate they're just so
accurate
you know they got like ultra amethyst on
you
guys
so they can you know have assists with
their [ __ ] mouse
oh [ __ ]
are the snipers gone so i ain't stepping
from this corridor
i know there ain't no more snipers
[ __ ]
i just
after they i hope they never i don't
want to see this mode ever again
oh they're bringing it back but they're
gonna bring more weapons
and they're gonna
drop the champion for rpg
that dude's cheating i'm sorry
tell me i'm wrong
wow
you telling me he okay all that life no
i i need xbox to stop favoring these pc
[ __ ] boys
at least
i'm done this is my last game
i just i just
i just don't like this nonsense i really
don't
[Music]
wow
i don't know highlighted melee behind
him
even got the lunch anymore
[Music]
this is my last game i just don't like
the inconsistency like
if i die in the other mode i know nine
times out of ten it's it's it's me but
like the other this mode
it's like i i that one dude he sniped me
and another person back to back no
scoping on the gravity lift
well i'm gonna require a reload between
shots no he probably had the uh the
human sniper
i'm not saying he was cheating but
i definitely saying someone's a little
suspect there
fiesta
um
this is not a bad map to play this one
they they got my money for it
they want that black and blue
kid
i saw the color scheme and i was like
yup without hesitation same thing with
the red and black i was looking for a
green one but didn't have one
so i went with a second
i'm doing better
wow we had the same weapon
i just that sentinel thing don't do that
for everyone else
you see a big difference
wow people got swords rockets yeah and i
got i saw someone next to me i have an
ar and i had a needler how is that fair
off snipe
the pulse okay
oh [ __ ]
got the sword
i want the sword to go on the rocket
hatch
oh my god
there's more ammo
come on
you learned
oh my god man
shoot me with like the most cheap
weapons in the game
yo i know there's an aimbot already in
the game i've been told by a few people
i've seen screenshots that's why i i
hate that they won't let me turn off
cross play
like microsoft needs to stop doing this
we all need to play games how about you
tell them to stop cheating
ever come across in gaming
it's been all that money just
[ __ ] wow he jumped up
thank you
[ __ ] all right
wow
nothing but gravity hammer on one side
hydra on the other
double kill
[Music]
hey be careful with those
wow
ah one more you got this
get it at it get the last kill and you
can do it you keep the last kill you can
do it
yeah yeah
did you see me chasing him down
well you can take my spot i'm done
no i want to play with you attic no i'm
done i'm done with this corny
everyone got rocked the game
it's going to play
hey we want to play some ranked
i'm good that's my last one too
all right
come in the fun's over
yeah i've been streaming for three hours
i was watching
yeah
yeah
well that's the end of the stream
gentlemen we uh
we are done
we are done
you know i got rocket launcher to death
i got hit with everything known to man
we are done no more no more rocket
launchers no more gravity hammers my
ears hurt because i've had the the
headset on so long but i'm done
i'll talk to you guys friday i'm going
to be streaming shinobi
i'm
confident that's a good day for me but i
appreciate it for coming through you
guys have a good day